in China for a female you know daily
life and a very stressful
so most female we haven't got a spare
time what a my spare time means that guy
is not your boyfriend I have a boyfriend
let's see we have boyfriend but that guy
also likes me a lot he knows I haven't
he's waiting to be a spare tire and they
spent how well really nice I'll bring
your coffee if the guy knows you have
boyfriend but he just the hoping one of
those days you guys then you were
becoming the real time super super
demanded in America you just go hang out
basically go and talk I plan maybe in
Sudan smaller they don't go to movies or
stuff they like to go top we take a
couple of beers and talk about our lives
most common theme is to go to a bar or a
pub for the first date and get to know
each other and have drinks and then you
never know where that's gonna lead into
sex on the first day like it's crazy
doing like it's not happening like if a
guy likes a girl he's really gonna be
super like over-the-top about it a lot
of times I would be like totally
appropriate to bring your tinder date
that you were like seeing for the first
time in a first date like 50 or 100
roses in Japan you like someone you take
the person out and then you guys go out
like twice so like three times and then
on the third or like fourth date like
well the person kind of like have to go
like oh I want you to be my girlfriend
boyfriend I want us together new
generation almost like Americans we want
a career we want either I really into
marriage yet it's
we're changing I would say currently
it's more mortar you can walk around and
you can really meet people you're on the
tube and you can check I feel like in
Brazil we don't literally talk about
relationshipgoals most people don't talk
about the marriage right away but if you
won't be offended or feel weird that's a
red flag from the get-go people don't
talk marriage they do mention about
marriage which is very important because
that's the way the community accept you
you shouldn't go around dating people a
maseeh we don't say it so high officials
they do like to compliment the girl the
man saying oh you look pretty because
probably they think they're winning some
points and they have more chances of
getting what they want this this
phenomena that's been going around and
rather than calling that person a sugar
daddy or sugar mama
Nicole sponsors so these sponsor they
definitely lose their inhibitions once
they've had a couple of drinks or so
guys don't like super like independent
women they are like no I'm the man so
I'm not gonna wash my clothes and I'm
not gonna like clean the house you're
the woman you should do that we are like
a patriarchal focused cultures the
parents wonder kids
get buried even after you get married
they want to stay with their son of
course you know the daughters they don't
expect the daughters to live with them
because you know they follow their
husband nice to see you dating someone
you do want your prize to meet your
future wife and they do give an opinion
whether this is good for you or not a
lot of factors right into it things such
as I don't try you know if your parents
are very traditional they would want you
to marry someone from the same tribe
because you were the same practical
cultural practices you've got the same
language in Shanghai a famous Park in
other people's Park there's a one corner
is a car the matchmaking corner so the
parents took their picture for their
kids then the road are all almost their
resume and what's the requirements for
dating put on that before this another
corner everybody knows so babies can
parents and parents dating for their
kids
[Music]